hey everybody we are here in London at
the Long cross studios to visit the set
of now you see me too this is the sequel
to the 2013 incredibly successful bank
heist flick so how did they pull off all
of those incredible illusions well
that's what we're here to find out let's
go inside my magic trick here is when
when I want things to disappear I just
say okay well when I do it is just magic
and then you just kind of go like that
or just point to it I'm here with Dave
Franco so this is obviously your second
time back yes how does it feel being
back on set with some of the same actors
it's very uncomfortable to just a lot of
man love and I thought you're about to
say is very uncomfortable you don't like
the cat no no no their level of love is
uncle yes exactly it probably makes
everyone around us life comfortable
have you ever expect to be here again
filming a second part it didn't cross my
mind but it's the kind of movie that can
lend itself to a sequel because it's all
created mythology and you know takes
place in this world that's both of the
real world and also created so it makes
sense that the story can continue past
where the first one ended how does it
feel being kind of the new kid on the
block
with everybody who's worked on who has a
little more practice already with the
magic oh I've already lapped them when
it comes to magic yeah it's okay uh no
it doesn't I guess it's a it's a
testament to how fun this job is that I
keep forgetting that I wasn't in the
first run that I'm the new person when a
movie there's so many different tricks
and we're so used to crazy visual
effects that we really put a lot of
pressure on making sure that everything
was practical that when you see it we're
not cutting around we're not cheating
you that we actually get to experience
the magic as if you were there a person
and use the friction to kind of flick it
up
perfect perfect dave is actually amazing
pretty cool huh
I thought was not possible from an actor
on in camera the truth is all the really
great illusions in the movie are hand
doubles you know people who are really
wonderful like this man here you can be
in it easy wanted to be your hand double
for the Finnerty exactly I heard that
you actually have been working a little
bit on adventure aside or like mind
readings no I'm horrible I'm the worst
at it but hopefully one day I can
hypnotize somebody come see the movie
come see the movie it's really great
you